رغم ان لجنه القوانين في مجلس النواب اعطت
اول اشاره للاتجاه المقبل عبر المصادقه
على مشروع القانون الا ان الخلافات لا
تزال قائمه حيث يرى الجمهوريون الذين
يسيطرون على مجلس النواب ان مكارتي قدم
الكثير من التنازلات لبايدن من اجل التوصل
لهذا الاتفاق تقول النائب الجمهوريه عن
كارولاينا الجنوبيه نانسيميس انها لن تصوت
لصالح هذا الحل اما مؤيد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في الحزب فاعتبروا ان
الاتفاق سيء النائب عن
تاكسيسلون الكفاح ضد تمرير القانون مهما
حدث الوضع لم يختلف حقيقه كثيرا بالنسبه
الديمقراطيين حيث اظهر بعض النواب شكوكا
مثل روكانا النائب عن كاليفورنيا الذي
اعتبر ان الكثير من ممثلي حزبه المعارضين
لاقتطاعات الميزانيه لا يعرفون بعد كيف
سيصوتون لكن ما ابرز ما ينص عليه هذا
الاتفاق المثير للجدل يتضمن الاتفاق سقف
الدين العام للولايات المتحده لمده سنتين
اي حتى ما بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 20
24 فيما لم يتضمن الاتفاق التخفيضات
الكبيره التي يريدها الجمهوريون رغم ان
الانفاق غير الدفاعي سيظل تقريبا من دون
تغيير السنه المقبله وسيزيد واسميا فقط في
العام 20 25 كذلك ينص على خفض عشره
مليارات دولار من الاموال المخصصه للخدمات
الضريبيه لتحديث وتعزيز الضوابط وهو ما
كان مطلبا للجمهوريين وكذلك استرداد
الاموال المخصصه لمكافحه كوفي 19 والتي لم
تنفق بعد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات